au sens d'un transistor qui diffusent de
la musique classique
le jeune psychologue médium et spirit
luis antonio caspary tôt en france
reçoit les esprits des peintres
impressionnistes
des peintures dictée par des esprits le
genre artistique fait un peu froid dans
le dos mais sachez que l'art médiumnique
comme on l'appelle rassemble depuis le
19e siècle de nombreux adeptes peintres
musiciens ou écrivain malgré ces gestes
rapides et précis cet artiste brésilien
disait n'avoir aucun don pour la
peinture
c'est à partir de ces treize ans que les
esprits ont commencé à s'emparer de lui
et parfois ça se bousculait un peu au
portier espère tous que ses communicants
comme un bon sens politique ou
personnalité du classicisme
impressionniste des esprits bien présent
banques et qu'ils laissent parfois que
très peu de répit à leurs artistes ici
en 1960
c'est le peintre espagnol diego
velazquez mort à la fin du xviie siècle
qui dicte à des oeuvres à cette femme
est ce qu'il veut des avants jean de
tableau que vous allez faire non
comment savez-vous que vous avez à faire
un paysage fait maman et après dix
minutes de transe
voilà le résultat
disons que velasquez était plus inspiré
de son vivant ci fasse un tel écart
jenny on peut douter de ces artistes un
peu exalté le cas de rosemary brown une
pianiste et médium anglaise peut
paraître lui un peu plus troublant les
célèbres chopin liszt ou bien encore
beethoven lui souffler régulièrement
quelques compositions
rien que ça on dit bien sûr on lui a
d'autres musiciens et ont expliqué que
certaines personnes fort doué pouvait à
la rigueur à imiter un des deux
musiciens mais que dans le cas par
exemple le cas km concernant le cas
madame brown lorsqu'on arrive à plus de
400 oeuvres musicales avec une telle
variété des musiciens alors là la chose
possible qu on reste perplexes ou pas
face à ces artistes d'un autre genre
certaines galeries n'hésite pourtant pas
à leur ouvrir leurs portes
l'exposition donne à voir des oeuvres
toutes très différentes
elle pose la question de l'au delà et
donne une réponse artistique aux
questions les plus ésotériques
[Musique]